it has a sweetness the same it's not
like it's a desert right it's a savory
meal yeah it's it's quite sweet like on
a hot summer day this would be amazing
[Music]
Marion Koreatown in Los Angeles at me me
Ranga to try the best soba from Korea it
was featured in Michelin Guide from
Korea and they are doing really really
really really good restaurant chain
right right yeah Kobus originally from
Japanese but this restaurant is from
Korea main thing that makes it stand out
is that it can be served cold they also
serve warm soba here the noodles you
know you have it in broth right so when
you have it separate and you like dip it
in the frog I like sweet noodles I don't
know why I look I don't like sweet
dreams but I like sweet it was sugar its
first week this is much different than I
expected this plating though you're
reminded a little bit of ramen in the
prison it looks like random but it's
weird with like I'm you cold the whole
tree start eating okay so good it's so
good it's so good really good with some
wasabi I do taste the sweetness right
yeah there's some sweet in there the
broth is like really Eve when they make
their broth it takes 24 hours yeah yeah
yeah you guys never tried on uni before
right this is there's only sea urchin so
I don't know you feel like it or not
it's very fishy
mmm it's very fishy that's good we think
why be me
[Laughter]
it's high I love and the noodles are
still the soba noodles yeah but we
noodles oh yeah that sweetness is not as
much there but there's like an int of it
yeah it's Morris Avery it's definitely
more savory this beef is so good
bruisers home bro yeah this is so good I
guess good again I heard from Japanese
chef the better you cook the soft-boiled
eggs the better restaurant in it so they
have to cook the eggs perfect this is
perfect so boiled egg yeah this is warm
so bubbly just had with is it seasoned
mad girl how do you make it boneless you
take the bones out well prepared it goes
together really nicely yeah I'll let the
heat you - oh yeah it tastes a little
sweeter the broth and everything is
pretty much the same I'm good at
differences of fishy flavor versus a
beefy flavor almost finishing everything
now
it's so easy to eat I'm incredibly full
which means that the meal was successful
it was so good me too
yeah my favorite that's so different and
it's so refreshing I think I'd be on
Team hot noodle but that might just be
because I'm a hot new duck down but I
will say that if you hadn't tried cold
noodles before this is incredibly good
and definitely would leave you full and
wanting to finish the whole thing it was
so tasty
[Music]
[Music]